i've got a secret
i would like to go over and personally
escort our
next guest on the show tonight
hello well then sir
will you tell our panel please let's get
in a little closer reminder for
pauliency there we go
you tell our panel please what your name
is and where you're from
my name's samuel j seymour i'm from
maryland
this is mr seymour from maryland and we
brought mr seymour all the way up from
maryland and by golly he got in the
hotel and fell down the steps and gave
himself a shiner
and uh we urged him not to come on the
show tonight as a matter of fact
and finally got in touch with his doctor
the doctor said it was up to mr seymour
mr seymour said he wouldn't miss it so
here he is
oh there mr seymour uh how old are you
by the way sir
96 96 years old
[Applause]
now sir if you whisper your secret to me
i'm sure the folks at home would like to
know what it is
well now to help classify his secret i
will tell you it concerns something that
he witnessed
and bill cohen will start with you
something that he saw something he saw
happen this thing that mr seymour
saw does it have historical significance
uh does this have historical
significance mr seymour i would say yes
wouldn't you sir
i can't hear him very good yeah there's
quite a distance between our desks here
let's
all speak up huh does it have uh does it
have political significance
it had political significance at the
time yeah yes
um well if you're 96
i would make mr seymour born in 1860
such a mathematician yeah he's been
writing over there all the time
this uh this thing didn't have anything
to do with the uh
civil war mr seymour uh no it had not to
do with the civil well uh let's say
indirectly it was concerned with the
civil war
did it come all right did it concern a
famous person
in in american history very well-known
person
did it concern a famous person mr
seymour yeah yep
would it help me to know who this person
was
he wants to know if it would help him to
know who this person was and he has to
know who that is yes
uh was this man did this man hold
political office
in this manhole political officer yeah
yes twenty dollars down and sixty
dollars to go and we go to jane meadows
henry is being his usual helpful self by
whispering to jane mckinley
and i'm not listening mr seymour would
this person have ever been president of
the united states
was he ever president this man i think
he was once
would it have been abraham lincoln it
was abraham lincoln yes
you witnessed something to do with
abraham lincoln was this a pleasant
thing
was it a pleasant thing you saw sir not
very pleasant i don't think
i scared the dancer he said no he was
scared to death would it have had
anything to do with the the president
lincoln's death
by any chance unfortunately yes did mr
seymour witness the shooting of
president lincoln
we found out about mr seymour through a
recent article in the american weekly
and said i saw lincoln shot this article
is by samuel j
seymour and it goes on to say that mr
seymour was five years
old at the time he had been taken to
ford's theater by some good friends
and the curious thing was that when he
was
this youth five years of age when he saw
booth
jump from the box to the stage at which
time he broke his leg
his only concern was not for the
president because he didn't realize
the president had been shot but the poor
man who fell out of the balcony
and that's all of his memory is of going
to the theater and seeing a man fall out
of the balcony
sir it's been a great joy and i might
say an honor to have you are by the way
the only
living witness of that tragic event and
we are certainly going to forfeit the
complete 80 dollars to you just for
your courage and coming here to see us
tonight